premier objectif
objectif numéro un c'est faire en mer
j'ai émergé en france d'ici 2030 des
réacteurs nucléaires de petite taille
innovant avec une meilleure gestion des
déchets sur ce sujet
pourquoi le mettre en premier le premier
sujet c'est la production de l'énergie
pour produire de l'énergie en
particulier l'électricité nous avons une
chance c'est notre modèle historique
le parc installé
de nucléaire j'aurai l'occasion de
revenir dans l'est dans les semaines qui
viennent sur l'opportunité de construire
de nouveaux réacteurs et sur la
stratégie puisqu'il ya d'abord un
travail que nous avons demandé avec le
premier ministre et la ministre à rte
continuera à avancer mais il faut bien
le dire le rappeler les 200000
françaises et français qui travaillent
dans le secteur du nucléaire c'est une
chance parce que c'est ce qui nous
permet d'être le pays en europe
qui est parmi ceux qui émettent le moins
deux tonnes par co2 par électricité
produite
nucléaire par qu'hydro et notre base
installée
nous devons ré investir pour être à la
pointe de l'innovation de rupture dans
ce secteur ça passe par une série de
familles technologiques m'appartient pas
ici de l'est de les trancher est celle
ci ne sont pas en quelque sorte
exclusive des choix industriels qu'on
doit faire aussi à plus court terme sur
à la fois le nucléaire et les énergies
non renouvelables mais nous devons
absolument nous préparer à des
technologies de rupture et
transformations profondes sur le
nucléaire la promesse de ce qu'on
appelle les small modula reactors qui
sont les petits réacteurs beaucoup plus
modulaire est beaucoup plus sûr parce
que la sûreté est un point clé du débat
sur le nucléaire les technologies pour
mieux gérer nos déchets certaines sur
lesquels nous commençons à avancer
certaines que nous n'imaginons même pas
avec là aussi un travail fait par nos
organismes de recherche qui pour
certains sont déjà très avancés par nos
grands industriels historiques et par
aussi d des entreprises de taille
intermédiaire des start up et des pme
françaises qui sont en train de proposer
des innovations de rupture en la matière
pour le il parvenir nous devons ouvrir
le jeu de manière totalement inédit et
nous sommes prêts à y investir un
milliard d'euros d'ici 2030 en
commençant très vite avec des premiers
projets très clair et donc là il faut
lancer plusieurs projets sur des
familles technologiques différentes mais
essayer d'avancer pour accélérer sur ce
volet c'est absolument clé parce qu'on
sait qu'on continuera à avoir besoin de
cette technologie est au fond on doit
traiter de sujets clés améliorer
toujours et encore la sûreté en baissant
les coûts et réduire les déchets qui est
un point clé quand on parle de nucléaire
[Musique]